[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis herzlich willkommen die
Champions League und mehr im Sport von
Norbert Lehmann einen schönen guten
Abend auch von mir und der
Haushaltsentwurf für 2024 kommt gar
nicht gut
weg Sparpläne unter Beschuss Bauern
Pendler und Sozialverbände kritisieren
die haushaltsentscheidungen der
ampelregierung Orban gibt nach Ungarn
verzichtet auf Blockaden der EU-Gipfel
macht den Weg frei für
Beitrittsverhandlungen mit der
Ukraine und Ende der Zettelwirtschaft
Minister Lauterbach will mit ehrrezept
und digitaler Patientenakte das
Gesundheitswesen
modernisieren die Einigung der
ampelspitzen auf einen Haushalt für das
kommendeen Jahr liegt auf dem Tisch aber
an den Einsparungen gibt es große Kritik
das Heizen und das Tank werden teurer da
der CO2 Preis stärker steigen soll als
geplant und auch Bäuerinnen und Bauern
drohen mit Protesten dafür sie
Subvention gestrichen werden mehr von
Daniel ponzen Volker Hahn Landwirt aus
Niedersachsen sieht sich und sein
Berufsstand besonders stark betroffen
von den angekündigten Einsparungen
bisher sind landwirtschaftliche
Fahrzeuge von der KFZ Steuer befreit und
zum Diesel gibt es Beihilfe beides soll
wegfallen wir fühlen uns schon als
Bauernopfer letztendlich muss man sagen
dass jeden Betrieb in der Region
Hannover irgendwo zwischen 6 bis 8000 €
netto im Geldbeutel betrifft und das ist
schon eine riesengroße Unverschämtheit
sorge für wirtschaftlichen Härten auch
für weite Teile der Bevölkerung äußern
zudem Gewerkschafter wie
Wirtschaftsexperten insbesondere das
Heizen und tanken zum Jahreswechsel
teurer wird durch die Anhebung des CO2
Preises sorgt für Kritik weil das im
Koalitionsvertrag versprochene klimageld
als Kompensation weiter auf sich warten
lässt es ist total wichtig dass die
jetzt erhobenen CO2 Preise tatsächlich
auch an die Menschen zurückgegeben
werden weil das klimageld noch nicht da
ist haben wir jetzt die EEG Umlage aus
dem Bundeshaushalt finanziert und damit
jetzt schon die Menschen bei
Strompreisen entlastet das klimageld SLE
trotzdem noch kommen frühestens jedoch
ab
2025 kritiker sagen zu spät denn die
Belastungen beginnen für viele schon in
wenigen Wochen wenn der CO2 Preis steigt
dann braucht in jedem Fall ein sozial
ausgewogenes klimageld den ansonsten
wird's gerade für die Menschen z.B
schwierig die in dem Ballungsraum
arbeiten aber außerhalb wohnen und
einfach weite Strecken zurücklegen
müssen oder die alte Heizungen alte
Häuser haben und für die dann eben sonst
kein Ausgleich da ist
ähnlich wie es Landwirte in ihrem
Bereich beklagen selbst
ampelagrarminister östemir äußerte
Bedenken angesichts der geplanten
Einsparungen hier es droh ein
Wettbewerbsnachteil gegenüber anderen
Ländern die an vergleichbaren
Vergünstigungen
festhalten die Europäische Union
eröffnet Beitrittsverhandlungen mit der
Ukraine diese Meldung kam vor einer
halben Stunde und voraus gingen wohl
intensive Gespräche mit dem ungarischen
Regierungschef Orban beim EU-Gipfel in
Brüssel orban hatte sich lange
quergestellt und die Einheit der anderen
26 Länder gestört die wollen ein starkes
Signal an den russischen Präsidenten
Putin senden Florian neuhahn vom ersten
Gipfeltag der Mann an dessen Veto alles
hängt muss am Morgen erstmal warten bis
ein Platz vor den Mikrofonen frei wird
dann lässt Viktor Orban Ungarns
Premierminister die Weltpresse Wissen
mit einem schnellen Jahr von ihm sei
erstmal nicht zu
rechnen wir sind hier nicht um Geschäfte
zu machen oder um einen Deal zu fschen
wir stehen ein für
Prinzipien es geht um die Frage ob
Europa 50 Milliarden Euro für die
Ukraine freigibt und es geht um die
Eröffnung von
Beitrittsverhandlungen wie so oft kurz
zugeschaltet der ukrainische prsidentens
anders als sonst stellt er seine Rede
später ins Netz in der er eindringlich
vor einem Scheitern
warnt putin wird das natürlich gegen sie
persönlich nutzen und gegen ganz Europa
schenken Sie ihm nicht seinen ersten und
einzigen Sieg in diesem
Jahr 26 der 27 EUStaaten sind auf
selenskis Seite die historische Fallhöhe
formuliert der finnische
was wir heute entscheiden und was nicht
das sendet ein klares Signal nach Moskau
nach Kiev nach Washington und
Peking Orban entgegnet dass die Ukraine
auch nach Ansicht der EU-Kommission bei
drei von sieben Bedingungen noch
nacharbeiten müsse bei der
Korruptionsbekämpfung dem Einfluss von
Oligarchen und dem Schutz nationaler
Minderheiten ich glaube es ist ganz
wichtig dass jetzt alle miteinander
sprechen und dass sie das mit der guten
Absicht sich zu einigen tun vor einer
halben Stunde die überraschende Wendung
zumindest bei einem Thema lenkt Orban
ein der Gipfel entscheidet
Beitrittsverhandlungen zu eröffnen mit
Moldau und auch der Ukraine hinter den
Kulissen wurde hart um eine Einigung
gerungen Ulf Röller hat das für uns
beobachtet Ulf wie ist die Verständigung
über beitrittsverhandlung mit der
Ukraine nun doch noch zustande gekommen
also es ging jetzt auf alle Fälle
schneller und es war doch auch eine
große Überraschung der Ratsvorsitzende
michelle war gerade da und hat eben
gesagt das ist ein ganz wichtiger Tag
für Europa und für die Ukraine ein Tag
der Hoffnung und das wird es wohl
gewesen sein die 26 die die Ukraine die
Gespräche aufnehmen wollten haben
massiven Druck auf Orban ausgeübt haben
klar gemacht wenn er nicht mitmacht
zerstört er diesen historischen Tag und
dann hat Orban einen Trick angewandt es
wurde abgestimmt und er selber ist
rausgegangen so musste er sich konnte er
sich quasi enthalten die Aufnahme der
Gespräche wurden angenommen und er
konnte ein bisschen in sein Gesicht
waren vielleicht noch ein Detail jetzt
beginnen langsam oder im März die
Gespräche mit der Ukraine dann wird es
aber immer wieder Gelegenheiten geben
dass der EU-Rat abstimmen muss und da
könnte Orban immer wieder ein Nein geben
aber erstmal bleibt es dass es ein
wichtiger Tag für die Ukraine ist und
wie sieht es beim zweiten Streitthema
aus den 50 Milliarden Euro
Wirtschaftshilfen für die Ukraine das
sieht es auch nicht so schlecht aus auch
da ist der Druck auf Orban groß ähm und
es heißt aus dem ungarischen lag dass er
durchaus kompromissbereit ist die 26
sind sich jedenfalls einig dass sie die
Ukraine finanziell stärk unterstützen
werden und sie sagen sogar wenn Orban
nicht mit machen wir das alleine ohne
ihn so viel zahlt er sowieso nicht also
auch da dürfte es ein positives Signal
für die Ukraine geben insgesamt heute
ein guter Tag für Europa und ein guter
Tag für die Ukraine danke für diese
Einordnung Ulf
Röller Russland halte weiter an sein
Zielen im ukrainekrieg fest so Präsident
Putin bei seiner jährlichen
Pressekonferenz es war die erste seit
Beginn des Krieges nach Angaben Putin
sein derzeit
617000 russische Soldaten in der Ukraine
im Einsatz eine erneute Mobilisierung
sei nicht absehbar nur ausgewählte
Fragen waren an Putin zugelassen ein
Bericht von Nina
Niebergall es ist ein gelassener
Präsident der heute die Bühne betritt
die Journalisten sind handverlesen die
Moderatoren sowieso zunächst eine Ansage
an die
Ukraine es wird Frieden geben sobald wir
unsere Ziele erreicht haben diese Ziele
haben sich nicht geändert ich erinnere
Sie daran die Entnazifizierung der
Ukraine die
Entmilitarisierung und ein neutraler
Status übersetzt heißt das die Regierung
und Präsident selenski muss weg Putin
demonstriert Selbstbewusstsein baut auf
nachlassende Hilfe aus dem Westen
die Ukraine produziert fast nichts mehr
selbst alles wird kostenlos
geliefert aber das könnte
enden auch die bürgerkommentare
sorgfältig kuratiert nur wer genau
hinschaut erkennt Risse in der
russischen idüle im Hintergrund Fragen
per SMS an Putin die da woh nicht
erscheinen sollten warum steht ihre
Realität im Widerspruch zu unserer
gelebten Realität steht da und in
unserer Straße in donjz gibt es seit 7
Tagen kein Wasser mehr wie lösen Sie
dieses Problem Sieg Stabilität und
wirtschaftliche Stärke so beschreibt
Vladimir Putin heute seine Welt er hat
das Land auf Kriegswirtschaft umgestellt
und trotz zu den Sanktionen beim Blick
auf den EU-Gipfel in Brüssel und den
Streit um die Unterstützung für die
Ukraine glaubt russlands Präsident den
längeren Atem zu
haben das vierstündige fernsehspektakel
dürfte der statsschuss für Putins
Wahlkampagne gewesen sein im März will
er sich erneut zum Präsidenten wählen
lassen haben hamasmitglieder in Europa
Anschläge auf jüdische Einrichtung
geplant laut Ermittlungsbehörden sind
mehrere Personen in Dänemark den
Niederlanden und auch in Deutschland
festgenommen worden in Berlin
durchsuchten Polizeikräfte Wohnungen von
drei Verdächtigen Waffen wurden keine
gefunden den Beschuldigten wird die
Mitgliedschaft in einer ausländischen
terroristischen Vereinigung
vorgeworfen und das ganze verfolgt für
uns Sarah Tacke Sarah was sollen die
Festgenommen genau vorgehabt
haben die vier mutmaßlichen Terroristen
sollen von der Hamas den Auftrag
bekommen haben ein erdversteck mit
Waffen aufzuspüren der
Generalbundesanwalt geht davon aus dass
mit diesen Waffen Anschläge auf Jüdin
und Juden in Deutschland und in Europa
verübt worden sein sollten allerdings
sind die Terroristen die mutmaßlichen
Terroristen nicht füig geworden so der
Stand der Ermittlung es sei viel mehr so
gewesen dass sie im Oktober mehrfach von
Berlin aus auf die Suche gegangen sein
diese Waffen aber bislang nicht gefunden
haben das heißt die gute Nachricht ist
dass die Ermittler den mutmaßlichen
Terroristen zuvorgekommen sind dass sie
relativ früh zugegriffen haben dass es
auch stand der Ermittlung jetzt noch
keine konkreten Anschlagspläne gab die
schlechte Nachricht ist allerdings dass
es offenbar ein Waffenversteck der
heramas in Deutschland geben könnte und
wie beurteilen Sicherheitsbehörden
derzeit ans allgemein die islamistische
Terrorgefahr in
Deutschland die Terrorgefahr in
Deutschland sei aktuell so hoch wie seit
lange nicht mehr warnt ganz konkret der
Verfassungsschutz Ermittler haben dabei
aber gar nicht so sehr hamasterroristen
wie die die heute festgenommen wurden
mutmaßliche hamasroristen im Blick
sondern die Radikalisierung im
Kinderzimmer das heißt sie sagen ganz
konkret die her Mass habe gezielt ihre
grultaten vom 7 Oktober gefilmt und ins
Netz gestellt und diese Videos könnten
nun in Deutschland lebende Jugendliche
in der regelen Alter zwischen 16 und 22
Jahren haben Ermittler gesagt motivieren
es den hamasterroristen gleich zu tun
das heißt über bombenbauanleitung im
Internet sich auf irgendeine Art zu
bewaffnen und dann auch hier Anschläge
zu begehen das heißt die Ermittler
fürchten konkret dass es sein könnte
nicht von der hammas gesteuert sondern
freiadikalisierte Jugendliche hier tätig
werden können und die sind natürlich
schwer zu überwachen weil sie sich in
ihren Kinderzimmern radikalisieren
könnten Sarah te vielen
Dank die Entsendung türkischer Imame an
Moscheen in Deutschland soll
schrittweise beendet werden darauf hat
sich die Bundesregierung mit der
türkischen Religionsbehörde und dem
moscheeverband dietip verständigt
dass die derzeit rund 1000 türkischen
Imame an deutschen Moscheen eingesetzt
werden ist umstritten weil sie Weisungen
der türkischen Regierung unterstehen
Deutschland will nun jährlich etwa 100
geistliche
ausbilden rund zwei Monate nach der
Landtagswahl in Hessen haben sich CDU
und SPD auf einen Koalitionsvertrag
geeinigt wenn die parteigrämien am
Wochenende zustimmen könnte er am Montag
unterschrieben werden nach der Wahl am 8
Oktober hatte sich die CDU von Minister
Präsident rin überraschend entschieden
das Bündnis mit den Grünen nicht mehr
fortzusetzen und stattdessen
koalitionsverhandlung mit der SPD
aufgenommen das Gesundheitswesen
digitalisieren und damit effizienter
machen diesen plän der Ampel hat der
Bundestag heute zugestimmt für erkrankte
geht es konkret vor allem darum bereits
ab Januar dürfen Praxen nur noch
ehrrezepte ausstellen die werden zentral
gespeichert und dann in den Apotheken
über über die Gesundheitskarte oder
einen Code
ausgelesen ab Anfang 2025 sollen dann
alle gesetzlich Versicherten eine
elektronische Patientenakte bekommen
wenn sie nicht ausdrücklich
widersprechen die Details zur E-Akte und
dem e-rezept hat Ines
Trams Hausärztin dr Heinle nutzt das
elektronische Rezept heute schon vor der
offiziellen Einführung im nächsten Jahr
per Klick lädt sie Rezepte auf die
Konten ihrer Patienten die sind
begeistert die Ärztin zwieg
alten die Patienten können dann einfach
in die Apotheke gehen müssen nur anrufen
und die Medikamente bestellen die sie
eben auch regelmäßig bekommen und haben
einen Fuß weniger ein Fußweg aber es ist
halt so dass wir die Patienten weniger
sehen werden und da weiß ich halt nicht
ob das am Ende des Tages dann vielleicht
auch ein bisschen ins Negative gehen
könnte ab 2025 dann soll die
elektronische Patientenakte diese aus
Papier ersetzen außer man widerspricht
das Ziel alles zentral einsehbar über
eine App Behandlungen rönkenbilder
medikamentenlisten ein Quantensprung
sagt der Gesundheitsminister im
Vergleich zu heute oft findet die
Behandlung aber dann auch ohne diese
Daten statt das führt zu Fehldiagnosen
zu Behandlungsfehlern in jedem Fall zu
einer suboptimalen Therapie umstritten
ist dass diese Gesundheitsdaten
verschlüsselt auch Forschung und
Pharmaindustrie zur Verfügung gestellt
werden sollen um beispielsweise die
Krebsforschung voranzubringen
einigermaßen verblüfft verblüfft darüber
mit welch gespielter Naivität die
Koalition bereit ist in den beiden
Gesetzen die privatesten die intimsten
die sensiblelsten Information der
Menschen zu veräußern nämlich die übere
Gesundheit jeder zweite Mensch in
unserem Land wird im Lauf des Lebens
eine Krebserkrankung erleiden und wir
werden alle in dieser Situation hoffen
die beste Diagnostik und Therapie zu
bekommen das kriegen wir nur mit
datensolidarität ein Schritt in Richtung
Digitalisierung ist gemacht doch es
bleibt ein langer Weg bislang nutzt
gerade mal 1% der Versicherten die
elektronische Akte
Entlastung für die Praxen und
Infektionsschutz im Wartezimmer wer zu
Hause ein krankes Kind betreut kann es
ab Montag telefonisch krank schreiben
lassen und Kinder Krankentage erhalten
das teilten Kassenärzte und
Krankenkassen mit Kinderkrankengeld kann
so für 5 Tage bezogen werden wenn der
Arzt oder die Ärztin das Kind
kennt eine juristische Niederlage für
die EU-Kommission der Gerichtshof hat im
Streit um Luxemburger Steuerregelung für
den versandriesen Amazon entschieden
dass dadurch keine illegale
finanzbeihilfe geleistet wurde damit
bestätigten die Richter ein früheres
Urteil und wiesen einen Einspruch der
Kommission zurück dem Onlinehändler
bleibt nun eine Zahlung in Höhe von 250
Millionen Euro an Luxemburg
erspart seit Tagen gilt in einigen
Regionen in Deutschland
Hochwasseralarm teilweise entspannt sich
die Lage etwas aber nicht überall so
stehen wie hier in Baden-Würtemberg
ganze Landstriche unter Wasser in
Riedlingen in Oberschwaben ist die Donau
über die Ufer getreten in der Nacht
mussten weitere Bereiche gesperrt werden
Richtung Wochenende soll sich die Lage
etwas
entspannen und jetzt kommen wir zur
Fußball Champions League und es war
wirklich ein spektakulärer Auftritt des
BVB gestern allerdings und das in
vielerlei Hinsicht ein wildes Heimspiel
gegen Paris Saint-Germain am Ende ein
harter kämpf des ein Z ein Ja und
bedeutet Platz 1 in einer monstergruppe
auch wegen einer monströsen
schwarzgelben gretsche die Szene des
Spiels gleich in der 18 Minute Niklas
süle verhindert artistisch einen
Torerfolg des Superstars mbappe ja dann
habe ich irgendwie den Fuß hochgissen
dann sieht es natürlich sehr spektakulär
aus im Anschluss viele Chancen auf
beiden Seiten Tore erzieltt aber niemand
besser im zweiten durchgangkrug auf EMI
Dortmund führt Paris Punkt raus aus der
Champions League braucht Tore und gleich
knapp 5 Minuten später durch seremery
aus der BVB wackelt süle diesmal weit
weg mbappés Ball fliegt ins Tor doch der
Franzose im Abseits durchs Schützenhilfe
maand PSG aber doch im Achtelfinale für
Dortmund bleibt die Champions League
eine
Wohlfühloase und RB Leipzig steht
ebenfalls als Gruppen Zweiter im
Achtelfinale im Heimspiel gegen die
youngbys Bern gestern Abend ein 2 Z ein
Sieg die Höhepunkte aller Spiele zu
sehen bei zdfheute.de und in der ZDF
heute App zum Wintersport da hat
snowboardin Ramona Hofmeister einen
perfekten Auftakt in die Weltcupsaison
hingelegt im italienischen karzza gewann
die dreimalige Gesamtsiegerin das
finalduell mit der östreicherin Daniela
ulbck die nach einem Fahrfehler
ausschiedt Hofmeisters 14 Sieg in der
olympischen Disziplin parallel
riesensladon beim beathlon Weltcup in
Lenzer Heide triumphierte im Sprint der
der Frauen Justine brisas busier aus
Frankreich beste deutsche Franziska Preu
am schiand fehlerfrei beim Laufen aber
nach überstandener coronainfektion nicht
so schnell wie bei den ersten
weltcupwettbewerben am Ende Platz 7 ein
starkes Comeback der 29-Jährigen aus
rupholding ja und ganz viel Wintersport
morgen wieder bei uns im ZDF ab 1405 Uhr
danke norwal gerne etwas Regen und
Schnee in den Bergen so sieht das Wetter
für morgen aus mehr dazu gleich von
östtin terle das heute journal läuft um
21:45 Uhr mit Anne gellineek und Morgen
begrüßt Sie hier Barbara hwig bis
[Musik]
bald schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter bevor das hoch die
wetterregie übernimmt mischt sich hier
noch eine Front ein in das Wetter
geschehen und bringt etwas Regen mit
aber auch zahlreiche Wolken die nach
Deutschland ziehen und Richtung
Wochenende wird es dann etwas milder in
der Nacht Schneid es an den Alpen weiter
hier also weiterhin Dauerschneefall
sonst auch Richtung östliche
Mittelgebirge Regen und in den höheren
Lagen Schnee und in der zweiten
Nachthälfte kommt von Nordwesten neuer
Regen auf und das bei tiefsten
Temperaturen von -3° hier in den
östlichen Mittelgebirgen und 4° ganz im
Westen ja und hier wo es frostig ist
müssen sie dann auch mit Glätte rechnen
und in den höheren Lagen mit dem Schnee
sowieso morgen dann im Tagesverlauf
weiterer Regen und Schnee das ist nicht
viel das kommt mit dieser Front was
allmählich südostwärts zieht und an den
Alpen lässt der Schneefall nach die
Temperaturen dazu maximal bis 9° im
Westen und 2° ganz im Osten und in den
nächsten Tagen am Samstag größtenteils
trocken nur etwas Regen nach Nordosten
in 2 bis 9° ja und am Sonntag wird es
schon etwas milder mit Werten bis 11 gr
einen schönen
Abend